Je suis l'homme le plus chanceux du monde.
J'ai pu voir le dernier cas de variole mortelle dans le monde.
J'étais en Inde l'an dernier,
Et j'ai peut-être vu les derniers cas de polio dans le monde.
Rien ne peut vous rendre plus conscient -- la bénédiction et l'honneur
de travailler dans un programme comme celui-ci que de savoir
que quelque chose d'aussi horrible n'existe plus.
Donc, je vais vous dire -- (Applaudissements) --
donc, je vais vous montrer de vilaines images.
Elles sont difficiles à regarder, mais vous devriez les regarder avec optimisme
parce que l'horreur de ces images sera associée
au réconfort de savoir qu'elles n'existent plus.
Mais d'abord je vais vous parler un peu de ma propre expérience.
Ma formation n'est pas exactement une formation médicale conventionnelle
à laquelle vous pourriez vous attendre.
Quand j'étais interne à San Francisco,
j'ai entendu parler d'un groupe d'Amérindiens
qui s'étaient emparés de l'île d'Alcatraz,
et d'une Amérindienne qui voulait accoucher sur cette île,
et aucun autre docteur ne voulait aller l'aider à accoucher.
Je suis allé à Alcatraz, et j'ai vécu sur l'île pendant plusieurs semaines.
Elle a accouché, j'ai pris le bébé, j'ai quitté l'île,
J'ai débarqué à San Francisco, et tous les journalistes voulaient me parler
parce que mes trois semaines sur l'île avaient fait de moi un expert en affaires indiennes.
Je me suis retrouvé dans toutes les émissions de télévision.
Quelqu'un m'a vu à la télévision, on m'a appelé, et on m'a demandé
si j'aimerais être dans un film et jouer un jeune docteur
pour un groupe de stars du rock qui voyageaient en bus
de San Francisco à l'Angleterre. Et j'ai dit oui, que je le ferais,
et donc je suis devenu le médecin dans un film absolument épouvantable
qui s'appellait "Medecine Ball Caravan."
Maintenant, vous savez que les années 60,
soit vous êtes dans le bus ou vous êtes hors du bus.
J'étais dans le bus. Ma femme et moi, nous sommes mariés depuis 37 ans, nous avons pris le bus.
Notre bus nous a emmenés de San Francisco à Londres.
Nous avons changé de bus au niveau de l'Océan Atlantique. Nous avons ensuite pris deux bus de plus
et nous avons traversé la Turquie et l'Iran, l'Afghanistan,
traversé la Passe de Khyber, pour arriver au Pakistan, comme tout autre jeune docteur.
C'est nous à la Passe de Khyber, et voilà notre bus.
Nous avons eu du mal à traverser la Passe de Khyber,
mais nous avons fini en Inde.
Et ensuite, comme tous les gens de notre génération,
nous sommes allés vivre dans un monastère dans l'Himalaya.
(Rires)
C'est comme un programme de stage,
pour ceux qui font des études de médecine.
Et nous avons étudié avec un sage, un gourou du nom de Karoli Baba,
qui m'a alors dit de me débarrasser de la robe,
de mettre un costume trois pièces,
de rejoindre les Nations Unies en tant que diplomate
et de travailler pour l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé.
Et il a fait une prédiction incroyable que la variole serait éradiquée
et que c'était le don de Dieu à l'humanité
à cause du travail difficile des scientifiques dévoués.
Et cette prédiction s'est réalisée, et cette petit fille est Rahima Banu,
et elle a été le dernier cas de variole mortelle dans le monde.
Et ce document est le certificat que la commission mondiale a signé
certifiant que le monde avait éradiqué la première maladie de l'histoire.
La clé pour éradiquer la variole a été une détection précoce, une réponse rapide.
Je vais vous demander de répéter ça, détection précoce, réponse rapide.
Pouvez-vous le dire?
Le public: détection précoce, réponse rapide.
Larry Brilliant : la variole a été la pire maladie de l'histoire.
Elle a tué plus de gens que toutes les guerres de l'histoire.
Au siècle dernier, elle a tué 500 millions de gens.
Plus de deux -- vous en êtes déjà à Larry Page
il y a quelqu'un qui lit très vite. (Rires)
L'année où Larry Page et Seguey Brin --
pour qui j'ai une certaine affection et une nouvelle affiliation --
l'année où ils sont nés,
deux millions de personnes sont mortes de la variole.
nous avons déclaré la variole éradiquée en 1980.
C'est la diapo la plus importante que j'ai jamais vue en matière de santé publique
parce que qu'elle vous montre qu'être les plus riches et les plus forts
et être les rois et les reines du monde,
ne vous protégeait pas contre la mort par la variole.
Vous ne doutez pas que nous sommes tous dans le même bateau.
Mais voir la variole du point de vue d'un souverain
n'est pas le bon point de vue.
Vous devriez le voir du point de vue d'une mère
qui regarde son enfant développer la maladie et qui est là impuissante.
1er jour, 2ème jour, 3ème jour, 4ème jour, 5ème jour, 6ème jour.
Vous êtes une mère et vous regardez votre enfant,
et le 6ème jour, vous voyez des pustules qui deviennent dures.
Le 7ème jour, elles montrent les cicatrices classiques de l'ombilication de la variole.
Le 8ème jour.
Et Al Gore a dit auparavant que l'image la plus photographiée au monde,
l'image la plus imprimée au monde,
était celle de la Terre. Mais c'était en 1974,
et à ce moment cette photographie était la photographie
qui était la plus imprimée
parce que nous en avons imprimé 2 milliards de copies de cette photo,
et nous les avons distribuées de mains en mains, de porte à porte,
pour montrer aux gens et leur demander s'il y avait la variole dans leur maison
parce que c'était notre système de surveillance. Nous n'avions pas Google,
nous n'avions pas de moteurs de recherche, nous n'avions pas d'ordinateurs.
Au 9ème jour, vous voyez cette image, et vous êtes horrifié.
Je regarde cette image et je dis, "Merci mon Dieu"
parce qu'il est clair qu'il s'agit seulement d'un cas ordinaire de variole,
et je sais que cet enfant vivra.
Et au 13ème jour, les lésions font des croûtes, ses paupières son enflées,
mais vous savez que cet enfant n'a pas d'infection secondaire.
Et au 20ème jour, alors qu'il gardera des cicatrices toute sa vie, il vivra.
Il y a d'autres types de variole qui ne sont pas de ce type.
Il s'agit de la variole confluente,
avec laquelle il n'y a pas un seul endroit du corps où mettre le doigt
sans être couvert de lésions.
La variole maligne, qui a tué 100% des gens qui l'ont contractée.
Et la variole hémorragique, la plus cruelle de toutes,
qui avait une prédilection pour les femmes enceintes.
J'ai probablement vu mourir 50 femmes. Elles avaient toutes la variole hémorragique.
Je n'ai jamais vu personne d'autres que des femmes enceintes en mourir.
En 1967, l'OMS s'est engagée dans un programme exorbitant
pour éradiquer une maladie.
Cette année-là, 34 pays ont été affectés par la variole.
En 1970, nous étions descendus à 18 pays.
1974, on en était à 5 pays.
Mais cette année-là, la variole a explosé dans toute l'Inde.
Et l'Inde était un endroit où la variole livrait sa dernière bataille.
En 1974, l'Inde avait une population de 600 millions d'individus.
Il y a 21 langues parlées en Inde,
cela revient à dire 21 pays différents.
Il y a 20 millions de gens sur la route à tout le temps dans les bus
et les trains, qui marchent, 500 000 villages, 120 millions de foyers,
et aucun d'entre eux ne voulait signaler s'ils avait un cas de variole chez eux
parce qu'ils pensaient que la variole était la visite d'une divinité,
Shitala Mata, la mère froide,
et c'était mal d'amener des étrangers à la maison
quand la divinité était chez vous. Pas incitant à signaler la variole.
Il n'y avait pas que l'Inde à avoir des divinités,
les divinités de la variole étaient prévalentes dans le monde entier.
Donc, voilà comment nous avons éradiqué la variole - une campagne de vaccination massive n'aurait pas marché.
On ne pouvait pas vacciner tout le monde en Inde,
mais un an plus tard il y aurait 21 millions de nouveaux nés,
ce qui était alors l'équivalent de la population du Canada
ça ne marcherait pas de vacciner tout le monde.
Il fallait trouver chaque cas de variole dans le monde
en même temps et dessiner un cercle d'immunité autour.
Et c'est ce que nous avons fait.
Rien qu'en Inde, mes 150 000 meilleurs amis et moi
sommes allés de porte en porte avec la même image
dans chaque maison en Inde. Nous avons fait plus d'un milliard de visites à domicile.
Et dans la démarche, j'ai appris quelque chose de très important.
Chaque fois que nous avons recherché de maison en maison,
nous avions une pointe dans les signalements de variole.
Quand nous ne cherchions pas, nous avions l'illusion qu'il n'y avait pas de maladie.
Quand nous avons cherché, nous avions l'illusion qu'il y avait plus de maladie.
Un système de surveillance était nécessaire
parce que ce qu'il nous fallait, c'était une détection précoce, une réponse rapide.
Alors, nous avons cherché et cherché, et nous avons trouvé
chaque cas de variole en Inde. Nous avons avions une récompense.
Nous avons augmenté la récompense. Nous avons continué à augmenter la récompense.
Nous avions une carte de pointage que nous écrivions sur chaque maison.
Et en faisant cela, le nombre de cas signalés dans le monde est tombé à zéro.
et en 1980 nous avons déclaré la planète débarrassée de la variole.
Ce fut la plus grande campagne dans l'histoire des Nations Unies jusqu'à la guerre en Iraq.
150 000 personnes du monde entier,
des médecins de toutes races, religions, cultures et nations,
qui ont combattu côte à côte, frères et soeurs, les uns avec les autres,
et pas les uns contre les autres, pour une cause commune pour rendre le monde meilleur.
Mais la variole était la quatrième maladie à éradiquer.
Nous avons échoué trois autres fois.
Nous avons échoué contre le paludisme, la fièvre jaune et le pian.
Mais bientôt nous pourrons peut-être voir la polio éradiquée.
Mais la clé de l'éradication de la polio est une détection précoce, une réponse rapide.
C'est peut-être cette année que nous allons éradiquer la polio --
ça en fera la deuxième maladie de l'histoire.
et David Heymann, qui nous regarde en webcast --
David, continue. Nous y sommes presque. Il nous reste 4 pays.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai l'impression d'être Hank Aaron. Barry Bonds peut me remplacer à tout moment.
Rayons une autre maladie de cette liste de choses terribles dont nous devons nous inquiéter.
Je reviens d'Inde où je travaillais sur le programme contre la polio.
Le programme de surveillance de la polio, c'est 4 millions de gens qui vont de porte en porte.
Voilà le programme de surveillance.
Mais nous devons avoir une détection précoce et une réponse rapide.
La cécité, c'est pareil. La clé pour découvrir la cécité
est de faire des enquêtes et découvrir les causes de la cécité
pour pouvoir mettre en place la réponse adéquate.
La fondation Seva a commencé avec un groupe d'anciens étudainst
du programme d'éradication de la variole qui,
ayant escaladé la montagne la plus haute,
ont goûté à l'élixir du succès d'avoir éradiqué une maladie,
voulaient le refaire.
Et ces 27 années, les programmes Seva dans 15 pays
ont rendu la vue à plus de deux millions de personnes aveugles.
Seva a commencé parce que nous voulions appliquer ces leçons
de surveillance et d'épidémiologie
à quelque chose que personne d'autre ne considérait
comme un problème de santé publique : la cécité,
qu'on pensait jusqu'ici être seulement une maladie clinique.
En 1980, Steve jobs m'a donné cet ordinateur, qui est un Apple numéro 12,
et il est encore à Katmandou, et il marche encore,
et nous devrions aller le chercher et le vendre aux enchères et gagner plus d'argent pour Seva.
Et nous avons mené au Népal la première enquête jamais faite pour la santé,
et la première enquête nationale sur la cécité jamais faite,
et nous avons eu des résultats étonnants.
Au lieu de trouver ce que nous pensions être le cas --
que la cécité étaient causée essentiellement par le glaucome et le trachome --
nous avons été stupéfaits de découvrir que la cécité était causée en fait par la cataracte.
Vous ne pouvez ni guérir ni prévenir ce dont vous ignorez la présence.
Dans vos sacs TED, il y a un DVD, "vision Infinie,"
qui parle du Docteur V. et de l'Hôpital pour les Yeux Aravind.
J'espère que vous le regarderez.
Aravind, qui a commencé en tant que projet Seva,
est maintenant le plus grand et le meilleur hôpital pour les yeux.
Cette année, cet hôpital rendra la vue
à plus de 300 000 personnes dans le Tamil Nadu, en Inde.
(Applaudissements)
La grippe aviaire. Je suis ici en tant que représentant de ces terribles choses --
celles-ci pourrait être la pire.
La clé de la prévention ou de la réduction de la pandémie de grippe aviaire
est la détection précoce et la réponse rapide.
Nous n'aurons pas de vaccin ou de stocks adéquats d'un antiviral
pour combattre la grippe aviaire si elle survient dans les trois prochaines années.
l'OMS simule la progression de la pandémie.
Nous en sommes à présent au stade 3 sur l'échelle d'alerte de la pandémie,
avec seulement un peu de transmission d'humain à humain,
mais pas de transmission soutenue d'humain à humain.
Quand l'OMS dira que nous sommes passés au niveau 4,
ce ne sera pas comme pour Katrina. Le monde tel que nous le connaissons s'arrêtera.
Il n'y aura pas d'avion dans le ciel.
Prendriez-vous un avion avec 250 personnes que vous ne connaissez pas,
qui toussent et éternuent, quand vous savez que certaines d'entre elles
pourraient être porteuses d'une maladie qui pourrait vous tuer,
pour laquelle vous n'avez ni antiviraux ni vaccin?
J'ai fait une étude des meilleurs épidémiologistes dans le monde en Octobre,
je leur ai demandé -- ce sont tous des spécialistes de la grippe --
et je leur ai posé les questions que vous aimeriez leur poser.
Quelles sont selon vous les chances qu'il y ait une pandémie?
Si cela arrive, quel en serait le degré de gravité?
15% d'entre eux ont dit qu'ils pensaient qu'il y aurait une pandémie dans les trois ans.
Mais pire que ça,
90% ont dit qu'ils pensaient qu'il y aurait une pandémie
au cours de la vie de vos enfants ou de vos petits enfants.
Et ils pensaient que s'il y a une pandémie,
un milliard de gens tomberaient malades.
Jusqu'à 165 millions de gens en mourraient.
il y aurait une récession mondiale et une dépression
alors que notre système d'inventaire réglé
et le mince bandeau élastique de la mondialisation se casseraient,
et le coût pour notre économie de 1 à 3 milliards de $
serait bien pire pour tout le monde que simplement 100 millions de morts
parce que tant de gens perdraient leur emploi
et leurs couverture de santé
que les conséquences en seraient presque inimaginables.
Et cela empire parce que les voyages s'améliorent tellement.
Permettez-moi de vous montrer une simulation de ce à quoi ressemble une pandémie
pour que nous sachions de quoi nous parlons.
Supposons, par exemple, que le premier cas se déclare en Asie du Sud.
Au début, cela évolue assez lentement.
Vous avez deux ou trois endroits discrets.
Et puis vous avez des foyers secondaires, et la maladie s'étendra
d'un pays à l'autre si vite que vous ne saurez pas ce qui vous frappe.
En trois semaines, elle sera partout dans le monde.
Maintenant, si nous avions un bouton annulation, et que nous pouvions revenir en arrière et l'isoler
et la saisir dès sa première apparition. Et si nous pouvions la trouver tôt,
que nous avions une détection précoce et une réponse rapide,
et nous pourrions mettre chacun de ces virus en prison --
c'est la seule façon de traiter une chose comme une pandémie.
Et permettez-moi de vous montrer pourquoi.
Nous avons une plaisanterie. Voici une courbe d'épidémie, et tout le monde en médecine,
je crois, finit par savoir ce que c'est.
Mais la plaisanterie est, un épidémiologiste aime arriver à une épidémie
exactement ici et surfer vers la gloire sur la courbe descendante.
Mais en général on ne fait pas cela.
En général on arrive pile ici.
Ce que nous voulons vraiment c'est arriver ici, afin que nous puissions arrêter l'épidémie.
Mais on ne peut pas toujours faire cela. Mais c'est une organisation
qui a pu trouver une façon d'apprendre quand les premiers cas surviennent,
et cela s'appelle GPHIN.
C'est le Réseau d'Information de Santé Mondiale Publique.
Et cette simulation que je vous ai montré et dont vous pensiez que c'était la grippe aviaire,
c'était le SRAS. Et le SRAS est la pandémie qui n'a pas eu lieu.
Et ça n'a pas eu lieu parce que le GPHIN a trouvé l'épidémie en gestation de SRAS
trois mois avant que l'OMS l'ait effectivement annoncé,
et c'est grâce à cela que nous avons été en mesure d'arrêter la pandémie de SRAS.
Et je crois que nous sommes très redevables au GPHIN et à Ron St. John,
qui j'espère est quelque part dans cette salle -- par là --
qui est le fondateur du GPHIN.
(Applaudissements)
Salut, Ron,
Et TED a fait venir Ron par avion depuis Ottawa, où le GPHIN est basé
parce que non seulement le GPHIN a trouvé le SRAS rapidement, mais
vous avez peut-être vu la semaine dernière que l'Iran a annoncé qu'il y avait la grippe aviaire en Iran,
mais le GPHIN a trouvé la grippe aviaire non pas le 14 février mais en septembre dernier.
Il nous faut un système d'alerte précoce
pour nous protéger contre les choses qui sont les pires cauchemars de l'humanité.
Et donc mon voeu à TED est fondé sur le dénominateur commun de ces expériences.
La variole -- une détection précoce, une réponse rapide.
La cécité, la polio -- une détection précoce, une réponse rapide.
La pandémie de grippe aviaire -- une détection précoce, une réponse rapide. C'est une litanie.
Il est si évident que notre seule façon de traiter ces nouvelles maladies
est de les trouver tôt et de les arrêter avant qu'elle ne se propagent.
Donc, mon voeu à TED est que vous aidiez à construire un système mondial,
un système d'alerte précoce,
pour nous protéger contre les pires cauchemars de l'humanité.
Et j'ai pensé à le nommer Early Detection (Détection Précoce),
mais il faudrait vraiment l'appeler Total Early Detection.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais pour être sérieux --
parce que cette idée est née à TED.
J'aimerais que ce soit l'héritage de TED, et j'aimerais l'appeler
le Système International de Détection Précoce Totale des Maladies (INSTEDD).
Et son acronyme en anglais INSTEDD deviendra alors notre mantra.
Donc au lieu d'une pandémie cachée de grippe aviaire,
nous la trouvons et la contenons immédiatement.
Au lieu d'un nouveau virus causé par une bio-terreur ou une bio-erreur,
ou un changement soudain ou une dérive, nous le trouvons, et nous le contenons.
Au lieu d'accidents industriels comme des marées noires ou la catastrophe de Bhopal,
nous les trouvons, et nous réagissons.
Au lieu de famine, cachée jusqu'à ce qu'il soit trop tard, nous le détectons, et nous réagissons.
Et au lieu d'un système,
qui appartient à un gouvernement et est caché dans les entrailles du gouvernement,
construisons un système de détection précoce
qui soit librement accessible à n'importe qui dans le monde dans sa propre langue.
Faisons-le transparent, non-gouvernemental,
qui n'appartienne pas à un seul pays ou une seule entreprise,
qui soit hébergé dans un pays neutre, avec une sauvegarde redondante
dans un fuseau horaire différent et dans un continent différent,
et construisons sur le modèle du GPHIN. Commençons avec le GPHIN.
Augmentons le nombre de sites qu'ils explorent de 20 000 à 20 millions.
Augmentons les langues qu'ils explorent de 7 à 70, ou plus.
Intégrons des envois de messages de confirmation
en utilisant les textos ou les sms ou la messagerie instantanée
pour trouver les gens qui sont à moins de 100 m de la rumeur que vous entendez
si elle est en fait valide.
Et ajoutons une confirmation satellite.
Et nous ajouterons d'étonnants graphiques sur Gapminder au premier plan.
Et nous le ferons grandir comme une force morale dans le monde,
en trouvant ces choses terribles avant que qui que ce soit d'autre n'en entende parler,
et en leur envoyant notre réaction. Pour que l'an prochain,
au lieu de nous rencontrer ici,
à nous lamenter sur toutes ces choses terribles qu'il y a dans le monde,
nous aurons uni nos forces, employé des compétences uniques
et la magie de cette communauté,
et nous serons fiers d'avoir tout fait pour arrêter les pandémies,
les autres catastrophes et changé le monde en commençant tout de suite.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Une présentation époustouflante. Tout d'abord,
pour que tout le monde comprenne, vous dites qu'en construisant --
en créant des moteurs de recherche, en cherchant des modèles sur Internet,
ils peuvent détecter quelque chose de suspect avant l'OMS,
avant que quelqu'un d'autre puisse le voir?
Expliquez-nous. Donnez-nous un exemple pour illustrer comment ce serait possible.
Larry Brilliant : Tout d'abord, vous n'êtes pas furieux de la violation du droit d'auteur?
CA : Non, j'adore.
LB : Et bien, vous savez, comme Ron St john -- j'espère que vous allez le rencontrer
au dîner tout à l'heure et lui parler --
Quand il a commencé le GPHIN en 1997, il y avait une apparition de grippe aviaire.
H5N1. C'était à Hong Kong. Et un médecin remarquable à Hong Kong
a immédiatement réagi en abattant 1,5 millions de poulets et d'oiseaux,
et a arrêté immédiatement cette apparition.
Détection immédiate, réponse immédiate.
Puis les années ont passé,
et il y avait de nombreuses rumeurs à propos de la grippe aviaire.
Ron et son équipe à Ottawa ont commencé à explorer le web,
en explorant seulement 20 000 sites web différents, pour la plupart des journaux,
et ils lisaient et entendaient parler d'une inquiétude au sujet de beaucoup d'enfants
qui avaient une forte fièvre et les symptômes de la grippe aviaire.
Ils ont rendu compte de cela à l'OMS. L'OMS a mis un peu de temps à réagir
parce que l'OMS ne reçoit de rapport que d'un gouvernement,
parce qu'il s'agit des Nations Unies.
Mais ils ont été en mesure de signaler à l'OMS et leur ont fait savoir
qu'il y avait un foyer surprenant et inexpliqué de maladies
qui ressemblait à celui de la grippe aviaire.
Il s'est avéré que c'était le SRAS.
C'est ainsi que le monde a découvert le SRAS.
Et grâce à ça nous avons été en mesure de stopper le SRAS.
Maintenant, ce qui est vraiment important est que, avant le GPHIN,
100% des signalements de mauvaises choses dans le monde --
qu'on parle de famine ou qu'on parle de grippe aviaire
ou qu'on parle d'Ebola --
100% de tous ces signalements venaient des Nations Unies.
A partir du moment où ces types à Ottawa, avec un budget de 800 000 $ par an,
se sont mis à la tâche, 75% de tous les signalements dans le monde sont venus du GPHIN,
25% de tous les signalements dans le monde
sont venus de toutes les autres 180 nations.
Maintenant, voici ce qui est vraiment intéressant,
après qu'ils aient travaillé deux ans,
que pensez-vous qu'il soit arrivé à ces nations?
Il se sont sentis plutôt stupides, alors ils se sont mis à envoyer leurs signalements plus vite.
Maintenant leur pourcentage de signalement est descendu à 50%
parce que les autres nations ont commencé à signaler.
Donc, pouvez-vous détecter des maladies de façon précoce en indexant le web?
Oui, bien sûr. Pouvez-vous trouver encore plus vite que le fait le GPHIN aujourd'hui?
Oui, bien sûr. Vous avez vu qu'ils ont trouvé le SRAS
en utilisant leur moteur de recherche Chinois pendant 6 bonnes semaines.
avant qu'ils ne le trouvent en utilisant leur moteur de recherche Anglais.
Et bien, il n'indexent que dans sept langues.
Ces méchants virus n'ont vraiment pas l'intention de se montrer
d'abord en Anglais, Espagnol ou Français.
(Rires)
Donc, oui, je veux m'inspirer du GPHIN, je veux construire à partir de là,
je veux ajouter toutes les langues du monde possibles,
je veux l'ouvrir à tout le monde
pour que le responsable de la santé à Nairobi ou à Patna, Bihar
y accèdent autant que que les gars à Ottawa ou au CDC,
et je veux que cela fasse partie de notre culture qu'il y ait une communauté
de gens qui surveillent les pires cauchemars de l'humanité,
cela soit accessible à tout le monde.